hi there I'm Anna Prosser Robinson for
GameSpot here at San Diego comic-con
2014 on the front line with some amazing
cosplayers could you guys introduce
yourselves and tell us who you're
cosplaying gasps I'm Ashley and I'm
dressed as Athena from Borderlands the
pre-sequel I'm an acai bowls and I'm
cosplaying mad Moxxi from Borderlands 2
and you're the strong silent type I'm
going to call you honky that's good okay
cool honky uh all right so what went
into creating costume like this did you
create it yourself or find it elsewhere
yeah everything I everything except the
gloves and boots pretty much I made
myself um
I sew a lot so I started there and the
gear box released a cosplay set of
pictures which made it super easy to get
all the details right but it's mostly
just foam wood and fabric what about you
what went into your costume a lot of
Tears I made my costume by hand as well
the only things
everything's been heavily altered like
the hat in the booster heavily altered
this is all sewn and painted by hand
because I'm obsessed well yeah it's a
fabric and like she was talking about
the cosplay guys really helped not for
this costume but for another one I'm
making it's just incredible you have to
kind of work around what you find and
like spend hours in a fabric store but
yeah this is all hours of Tears and
painting sewing I wrote about you I'm
assuming this took a long time yeah
didn't take a long time like less than a
week less than that two days two weeks
two weeks okay this is good it's like
cosplay charades all right two weeks ah
did you use worbla no some other
materials it's oh it's like foam like I
don't know where you got that foam but
it's really that would probably be a
little bit nicer to move around floor
mats yeah it's a cosplay staple you just
pick up a bunch of those interlocking
floor mats make armor with them very
cool
I learned something well before we start
off will you tell me what's your
favorite part of this ensemble Oh
I think my favorite part has to be the
vest I really like the best it's
beautiful and you sewed that yourself
yes yes it was labor of love of vinyl
and craziness but I'm really loving it
is there anywhere that people can check
out more of your cosplay minds at you
can just I just update on Twitter mostly
its Twitter slash cracker bits bi TZ and
what about you I'm for Facebook page
it's just facebook.com/blackdogeducation
included there we try to get a lot of
cosplayers together just post the
pictures of everybody it's very cool
awesome community so Pandora's most
wanted for you your money prompts I hope
you heard that alright guys thank you so
much let me know what you think of these
costumes and if you've seen any other
awesome cosplay or especially
Borderlands cosplay by tweeting at me at
Anna Prosser